so I strongly disagree that every police
officer should advertise I've been fired
at children they've been fired at a
blind man someone actually died from
being tased
first of all tasers don't kill people
you know the horror stories of their
exaggerated so you need to sort of just
understand what you look quite familiar
to me
I certainly you know I've known of your
name I don't think we've ever paths
across directly strongly disagree we'd
rather they had guns the thing I don't
like about it sizes is when the police
we're asking for them they said are they
be used in special circumstances they'd
only be used under certain rules but
like anything else that you give to a
kind of uniform body everyone's going to
want to try them out and we found out
since that they've been fired at
children they've been fired at a blind
man carrying a walking stick and that
someone actually died from being tasered
so I strongly disagree that every police
officer should advertise oh I think
there should be a certain squad there
trying to use them and they should be
called on if they're needed few things
in there first of all
tasers don't kill people you know the
horror stories about yeast on a kid well
sometimes they're exaggerated so you
need to sort of just understand what
what they're for yes then they feel like
I've read a lot of the information on
the Moors quite interesting because then
we're going to give them the prison
offices at one stage as well and I just
that I just completely disagree with
using stuff like that on anybody
rather than and not just kids but you
need to be aware what children are in
the media headlines they're under 18
who's going around stabbing each other
to death in horrendous circumstances a
moment it's children
prisons are violent brutal horrible
places where people get killed more
people die in our prison system then you
know used to die when we had to
definitely and most of them by hanging
even the boredom on its own is enough to
kill you I was in nine months in
solitary with nothing and I went mad and
a lot of people who go to prison with
long sentences end up in psychiatric
hospitals but with the staffing cuts
with the pressures with the levels of
violence going up with everything that's
happening there's significant harm to
prison officers gone well I can I'm
speaking from experience here my first
ever experience at police was actually
being kidnapped off the street at the
edge of full trading with a mate of mine
and being basically tortured and abused
by police officers with a drunk a
burglary squad to get us to admit to
both ways we'd never committed from
there or I became a criminal and so did
more power I can understand how that
that would the vast majority of cases
are not like yours mark and a few in
those days but I can understand where
you're coming from
it depends on what you mean by her
physically physically I'd be here
psychologically I'd sort of be here I
guess I think I've got a change to
strongly disagree maybe I'd go to
disagree but like I say it depends if we
talk in physical or psychological her
psychological hurt they hurt people it's
unusual for bank robbers to be shooting
people
my wife was recently in an armed robbery
she was a witness in an armed robbery up
in Croydon I realized I have done five
years in therapy and I had met the
victims of armed robbery and I realized
that traumatizing it was but to see your
own wife for days afterwards being
affected by you then realised that you
know no matter even if you think you are
some sort of Robin Hood gentleman bank
robber or whatever you're not because he
first didn't the people's lives and
you're imposing your will on them you
know basically most crimes are gonna
hurt somebody
I came very close
probably about less than a millimeter
away all I could see was the back of his
head I mean a colleague covering him put
you exactly one hand went down so we
yelling at and put the hand back when he
did I realized that the trigger had been
being pulled and then as I sort of
relaxed away from it as his hand came
back I real you know that was close and
I reckon it was less than a millimeter
away so yeah it changes your life I
think even picking up a gun for a
criminal changes your life it's only a
small step there shooting somebody as
you will notice and pull of the trigger
you'll have seen people I've met
criminals that are fired shots and it's
totally changed them some of them it
destroys them I just realized what their
damage they're causing true
yeah I'm hopefully going to then again
we come from a generation where we'd be
sitting across the table at a point I've
just charged you with three armed
robberies or something and we'd be
having this conversation yes yes nice to
meet you as well
you